[Musique]
Guillaume palavant bonjour bonjour merci
de nous recevoir en plein accrochage de
l'exposition BD qui démarre samedi à la
mairie de Versailles alors déjà j'ai
envie de parler un petit peu de vous qui
êtes-vous Guillaume pasavant dites-moi
tout donc j'ai une agence
d'événementielle autour de la bande
dessinée que j'ai monté il y a 6 ans qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle l'agence EV BD
et qui est basé à versaill d'accord
cette agence a pour principale activité
de promouvoir la bande dessinée à
travers des expositions ouais donc je
travaille pour à la fois pour versaill
où c'est la 6e année que je monte une
exposition just c'est la 6 exposition
qui a lieu dans la mairie de versaill la
maie de Versailles et en activité
parallèle évidemment j'ai je monte des
expositions à travers la France je suis
le responsable BD du salon de livre de
Paris depuis 6 ans aussi où je je
coordonne toute la bande dessinée donc
c'est un c'est un milieu que je connais
bien ben j'espère pour vous il serait
temps et dites-moi alors cette
exposition là elle démarre donc samedi
samedi 5 avril jusqu'au 4 mai av jusquau
4 mai donc un mois elle sera ouverte au
public l'après-midi je crois de 12h à
18h tous les jours 1218 tous les jours
d'accord même le samedi le dimanche même
le samedi le dimanche alors cet expo euh
on voit sur les affiche Il il est écrit
collection signée c'est ça c'est-à-dire
C d'habitude alors c'est quoi ça
correspond à quoi déjà collection signée
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire collection
signée c'est les éditions du Lombard
ouais euh ont lancé il y a 20 ans h une
collection qui s'appelle la collection
signée c'est nom la collection c'est nom
de la collection et qui donne qu' y a
pas de e c'est pas e e c'est un
N collection a pour principe que de
donner euh euh de donner la possibilité
aux grands auteurs de bandes dessiné ou
même à des à des jeunes de euh montrer
un roman graphique un album en un ou
deux volumes donc une histoire complète
terminée alors qu'en band dessiné on est
très habitué à des séries sans fin comme
luckyc comme les Schtroumpf où ça peut
s'arrêter comme jamais s'arrêter voilà
donc là le principe c'est c'est c'est
vraiment des des romans graphiques de un
ou deux volumes qui racontent une
histoire terminée et on demande à des
grands scénar Paris tu as des grands
dessinateurs mais il y a même des jeunes
dessinateurs qui vont dans cette
collection ou c'est une lettre ouverte
c'est c'est c'est une ouverture une
possibilité pour les pour le pour
l'éditeur et de de proposer donc une
collection variée qui est vraiment très
variée il y a la fois de la
science-fiction il y a de l'aventure il
y a l'espionnage il y a tout a tout ce
qu'on veut dans cette collection
d'accord donc ce qui les rassemble c'est
que ce sont ce que vous appelez des
romans graphiques à savoir une œuvre qui
est un début un milieu une fin qui peut
avoir éventuellement un deuxème tome
mais pas plus voilà exactement et qu'on
peut lire donc
épendpend chaque vre est indépendante
voilà et donc dans la BD il y a le roman
graphique dont on parle dans la
collection signée et les BD de séries
don parle pas voilà exaement qu'on parle
pas aujourd'hui les 5 premières années
euh François de maierre lorsqu'il m'a
demandé de monter maire de versaill
lorsqu'il a demandé de monter la
première exposition on est parti on a
rendu hommage au grand nom de la bande
des ciné donc on a fait en général on a
fait c'est une exposition par auteur
donc on a fait Juillard Vance Philippe
Franck pour l'argonch voilà rosanski
pour torgal et cette année on a voulu
faire un peu autre chose et même c'est
une ouverture c'est-à-dire que là on va
avoir il doit y avoir 120 œuvres
originales mais là c'est vraiment on va
montrer la diversité graphique
c'està-dire que et ben quand on va se
promener dans l'exposition on verra à la
fois des planches couleurs en aquarelle
des noirs et blanc des crayonnés il a
qui travaille qu' d'inatique voilà il y
a on va voir vraiment tous les styles et
c'est au contraire cette exposition par
rapport aux autres c'est vraiment la
variété on va vraim VO donc elle est
très pédagogique si je peux pe dire
parce que ça montre tout les quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui exactement quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui veut se lancer un jour
dans bande dessinée s'il va voir
l'exposition il verra un peu tous les
supports possibles tous les supports
possibles et puis faç et donc pardon je
vous coupe mais là vous allez accueillir
combien d'auteurs en chair et en no en
CH en no on a à peu près 15 à 17 auteurs
et ça se réparti comment alors ben ils
viennent par weekend c'est par donc il y
a un programme précis qui est disponible
sur le site de la ville versaill.fr je
crois et toutes les et qui qui
actualisent et les auteurs viennent dans
dédicace le samedi et le di
et autrement en semaine on accueille le
public de 12h à 18h les écoles voilà
c'est ouvert pendant toutes les vacances
de pâqu voilà et puis comme chaque année
on
a pour le public et pour les
collectionneurs on a fait un tirage
spécial de deux albums comme chaque
année on propose un tirage spécial in
inédit à versaill c'est qu'on a pris
deux bestseller de cette collection on a
pris l'album qui s'appelle bouche du
diable de Bou et charine ouais et on a
pris mesec de juyard et Yann on a un
tirage spécial à 350 exemplair
qui sont disponibles qu'ici lors de
l'exposition d'accord et il y aura les
auteurs j'imagine et les auteurs oui
vont venir oui ils vont bien les signer
et ils vont venir les signer puis
surtout qu'on a un ex signé par l'auteur
on a voilà et ça c'est vraiment à chaque
fois une exposition événement unique il
se passe quelque chose qui se passera
jamais ailleursa jamais lieu et on
l'avait fait aussi pour les autres
annéés à chaque fois on a un album
unique et à chaque fois on arrive à le
faire vous arrivez à le faire ce qui est
formidable et vous avez un monde fou
j'imagine ça va oui oui non non ça ça va
on c'est un peu compliqué à gérer les
déd d'année en année parce que c'est
tous les ans c'est tous les ans mais
maintenant oui ça progresse par rapport
à la première année en fin de compte ça
progresse il y a toujours du monde ça
c'est on a une chance énorme mais là on
a l'avantage ça progresse surtout en
terme de durée d'exposition la première
exposition a duré une semaine la deuxème
a duré 2 semaines et là on en est
presque à 5 semaines d'exposition voilà
d'accord parce qu'il y a des vacances à
l'intérieur où il y en a tout le temps
non il y a souvent des expositions mais
c'est cette salle qui est pas mal prise
et comme la salle des fêtes elle est
beaucoup utilisée et j'ai la chance de
qu'on voula les libéreron les bloqué
pendant un mois et du fait qu'on est
bloqué pendant un mois ça permet d'avoir
cette manifestation qui peut durer
longtemps d'accord et vous avez des
visites d'école j'imagine on peut
prendre encore rendez-vous
pour il a pas de problème on les
accueille et puis on leur fait une
visite privée et ben écoutez c'est
génial bravo merci plein de succès et
puis maintenant on va laisser la parole
à un de vos auteurs justement qui va
être présent un certain weekend il va
nous dire lequel et on va découvrir son
travail plus en détail merci
[Musique]
Guillaume
Cédric Babouche bonjour bonjour merci de
nous avoir rejoint donc justement
pendant l'accrochage de cette fameuse
exposition collection signée à la mairie
de versaill vous alors vous vous êtes là
en tant qu'auteur oui en tant que très
jeune auteur si j'ai bien compris parce
que vous allez signer votre première
œuvre dans la collection signée tout à
fait avant vous faisiez quoi Monsieur Je
c'était pas avant c'est toujours c'est
toujours maintenant fait plusieurs
choses plusieurs choses en même temps je
travaille maintenant depuis 10 ans dans
le cinéma d'animation en tant que
réalisateur et directeur artistique
d'accord donc je suis j'ai réalisé des
séries pour M6 je suis en train de
réaliser un film pour France Télévision
actuellement qui va sortir qui va sortir
à Noël a un titre déjà qui s'appelle
little oudini qui est sur la jeunesse
fictive du magicien Harry oudini très
bien voilà donc qui est un film
d'animation en 2D pour en pour les
enfants quel âge c'est du du 4 100 on
dira c'est assez large c'est vraiment
prévu pour que pour les f de fin d'année
et que tout le monde puisse se retrouver
devant la télé d'acord et parallèlement
à ça vous dessinez parallèlement à ça
une carrière de professeur par je je
suis j'ai une formation de dessinateur
au départ je suis dessinateur je suis
allé vers l'animation où je je réalise
et j'anime moi-même et puis via ma
formation que j'ai eu à l'école éilcole
à Lyon je suis quelqu'un d'assez
polyvalent donc je suis capable de faire
de l'animation mais aussi l'illustration
et la mre dessinée d'accord et il y a
maintenant un un an et demi Xavier
d'Orizon qui est un scénariste assez
connu et qui est enseignant à l'école
qui est enseignant à l'école Émile co
avec moi à Ly à Lyon m'a proposé ce ce
magnifique projet qui s'appelle le champ
du CNE le champ du signe c'est le nom de
votre prochain du premier album il sera
le premier et celui-là il sera en une
fois ou il y aura
un de Tom pas plus ça s'arrête ça
s'arrête ah oui non de touteçon ça va
s'appeler le champ du signe le champ du
signe tout d'accord donc là aujourd'hui
euh aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous avez
des choses à nous montrer même si le
l'album n'est pas encore physiquement
sorti il sort en septembre effectivement
d'accord donc vous allez présenter quoi
cette exposition al cette exposition je
vais présenter trois planches originales
d'cord euh je travaille en aquarelle
donc sur sur feuille tendue comme on dit
à l'ne à l'ensene euh à l'aquarelle
exactement donc pour chaque planche pour
chaque planche pour chaque planche de la
du roman graphique oui tout à fait nous
aurons une planche à l'aquarelle au
départ
au départ je fais ce qu'on appelle le
crayonnet et l'ancrage donc le travail à
l'ancre mais je le fais sur ordinateur
d'accord j'imprime cette ancrage sur
papier aquarelle avec une imprimante
laser et je fais mon aquarelle
par-dessus d'accord une fois que ce
travail est fait je rescanne mon dessin
mon Aquarel qu'on peut voir derrière
ouais et sous ordinateur je remets je
remets mon trait par-dessus pour
récupérer du détail de la finesse et une
fois travailler après sur ordinateur et
alors après et une fois que ça c'est
fait j'ai plus qu'à me mettre les bulles
et les et ça et alors justement en
parlant de bu et de dialogue qui qui
écrit les textes Xavier d'Orizon et
Emmanuel RZ qui sont donc les deux
coscénaristes du livre qui n fournit
tout tout le scénario ainsi que ce qu'on
appelle le découpage donc
laors le découpage c'est la préparation
page par page de ce que va être l'album
en fait page 1 on dit que tel personnage
parle avec telle personne dans telle
bulle tel cadrage on est dans un plan
large on est dans un plan serré et
cetera comme au cinéma comme au cinéma
la BD c'est du cinéma de toute façon
c'est du cinéma d'accord d'accord alors
ça prend combien de temps pour écrire un
roman graphique alors un scénario je je
suis pas le plus am même de vous dire
mais en gros quand il est écrit et quand
vous vous mettez à travailler avec
l'auteur et vous le dessinateur alors
moi je pense je suis quelqu'un d'assez
rapide donc l'album m'a pris tout
compris en sachant que je réalise le
film en même en parallèle je réalise le
film don je par je le réalise en
parallèle un autre film non le film sur
oudini je le réalise en je l'ai réalisé
en parallèle de la BD je suis d'accord
mais vous vous faites pas le film de la
BD non non non non non on s'est pas
compris si si on a compris
et donc en gros globalement en temps
réel j'ai mis 6 7 mois pour faire
l'album d'accord pour dessinerou ouou
avec les conversations et exaement alors
qu'en général on dit que la moyenne
c'est entre entre 6 et 1 an voire
beaucoup plus pour certains destinateurs
et alors cette rapidité est-ce que c'est
dû c'est une question sûrement idiote
mais je la pose quand même au fait que
ça so de laaarelle et que l'aquarelle
une fois que c'est jeté sur papier on
peut plus refaire et il faut forcément
aller vite ou pas non il y a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
raisons à ça déjà je pense que mon
expérience en dessin dessin d'animation
ma faculté à m'organiser à planifier un
travail dans une production qui demande
beaucoup plus de moyens financiers et
avec beaucoup plus de personnes mont
habitué à m'organiser d'une certaine
manière d'accord euh et deuxièmement
effectivement l'aquarelle moi j'en fais
depuis que j'ai 12 ans j'en ai 37
maintenant donc j'en fais depuis
longtemps quoi et et moi personnellement
je vais beaucoup plus vite en étant sur
le papier avec mes pinceaux que devant
l'ordinateur d'accord et euh et ça me
permet de gagner beaucoup beaucoup de
temps effectivement à l'arrivée d'accord
donc après ces planches sont exposées
après qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec ces planches elles sont
vendues elles sont vous les garder alors
euh oui effectivement il y a déjà des
galeries qui m'ont approché pour savoir
si j'étais prêt à les vendre alors oui
j'ai envie d'en vendre parce
que j'ai envie de dire oui effectivement
euh mais pas forcément pour l'aspect
financier j'ai envie que les gens voient
mon travail tout simplementjà euh après
euh en tant qu'auteur j'ai envie envie
de garder les plus belles pour moi pour
ma famille pour ma fille pour mes
enfants que ils les gardent pour plus
tard s'ils ont envie de garder mais
c'est vrai que la BD est un monde
où financièrement c'est pas toujours
toujours très évident de joindre les
debouts et donc la revente de planche
est aussi un Ort financierment d'accord
ben écoutez Cédric Babouche merci
beaucoup vous sortirez donc votre roman
en septembre en septembre voilà et votre
film en décembre en décembre ent
enttemps en novembre un livre
d'illustration également avec une petite
maison d'édition qui avait été fondée
par l'ancienne présentatrice télé
maindor voilà ah oui voilà tout à fait
très très bien et ben écoutez on en
reparlera on enarlera avec plis par
c'est riche mercici
[Musique]
auir